well the markets are coming off the
biggest two days of losses since
February the Dow Jones Industrial
Average lost nearly 546 points yesterday
a 2.1 percent drop on top of an eight
hundred and thirty one point plunge on
Wednesday the S&P 500 was also down 2.1
percent yesterday CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
what's behind the sell-off Jill can we
expect another sell-off this morning
it looks like the futures markets are
actually pointing higher but you know a
lot of this selling has to do with
something very peculiar it's actually
the strength of the economy as the US
economy has strengthened the Federal
Reserve has increased short-term
interest rates now longer-term interest
rates are rising as well and there is
some fear among investors that that rise
in interest rates could choke off the
big expansion that's going on 3% this
year and also it makes bonds very
appealing so if you made a bunch of
money in big tech stocks you can now
sell some of that move into a ten-year
Treasury and earn three point one three
point two percent not a bad place to
hide course the Fed always wants to
stave off inflation right yet the
president seems to lash out at the Fed
but calling Federal Reserve Chairman
Jerome Powell Loco
how unusual is that well calling him
loco is definitely unusual the thing
that's very interesting is Powell of
course is the president's choice to lead
the Fed and the feds got a big job ahead
of it
you know it's trying to say we've got to
stay ahead of inflation before it starts
to bubble up and we also have to foster
an economy that creates lots of jobs
well the job situation is fantastic we
found out that last month the
unemployment rate dropped to a 49 year
low and we are seeing some signs of a
little bit of price pressure not too
much though and the Fed has said they're
gonna keep raising rates because they
expect things to keep going well from
now until 2020 which happens to be an
election year right and so let's be very
clear that the strength of the economy
right now is something that we're going
to be looking at going forward
but it's also going to be very important
we've got earnings season coming up
we'll find out from companies how they
think they're gonna do going forward and
also how trade policies might be
impacting them because now we're
starting to feel the impact of the
tariffs in certain industries
all right the opening bell is just a few
hours away we'll be watching
you jealous